chaque fois que nous laissons une
sorcière libre d'agir
le malin accroît son pouvoir ce retour
est bien ici ma petite fille
obliger à sociale
les sorcières cesseront d'exister
lorsque vous cesserez de les mener au
bûcher jeux n'étaient pas faits étudiés
pour que tu t'es révolte contre ton père
c'est elle
[Applaudissements]
un des n'ai pas peur
justement nous t'attendions
vous vous demandez sans doute qu'il nous
sommes
voilà nous sommes votre famille parce
que nous représentons pour le plus
terrible et étrangers
nous possédons tout une force tu sais il
suffit de découvrir ce que c'est et de
ne pas en avoir peur
[Musique]
nous découvre ici s'en serait fini de
dons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier le plus grand des pouvoirs
et la connaissance de tous
[Musique]
les événements terribles sont sur le
point de tenir s'ils nous découvre ici
s'en sera fini de nous les sorcières que
tu te donne tant de peine à défendre
nous sommes prêts à les traquer une à
une jusqu'à ce que nous les aimons tout
déloger de leurs alliés je veux qu'ils
ne restent pas mamie sol il rafle des
femmes
ils les enlèvent une à une sans
distinction depuis corps risque-t-on
trop gros essayer de sauver des femmes
je pensais que c'était cela notre
mission où es tu
non madame
nos ennemis se prépare à tout nous
détruire à nous effacés de la surface de
la terre